TROPHY.
LOOKING FOR FORSBERG. S
FORSBERG BACK TO THE POINT.
ROMAN A
PERF
GETTING LOOSE.
HE FIRES ONE IN ON FILIP FORSBE
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
GOBBLED UP IS
NICK COUSINS. MAKES  SENSE BECA
THEY ARE STILL PLAYING HOCKEY.
THAT IS CALGARY
ON SATURDAY.
THE SAN JOSE SHARKS
TURNED ASIDE BY REIMER.
RIGHT ON
TRYING TO GET ONE OUT IN FRONT
HE ANSWERED ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS.
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
>> Bob: FORSBERG.
>> Cassie:
TURNOVER.E IS COUTU
GETS A STICK UP TO THE FACE,
AND WE THAT ALLOWS TRENIN
ON NE
SHARKS ARE PLAYING THROUGH,
THERE'S A CHANCE AT THE OTHER
END ON THE POWER PLAY.
WATCH THE STICK PLAY
THERE IS A SHOT. HE TURNS , RIG
CIRCLES.
BECAUSE FILIP FORSBERG
JUST MISSES. AND NOW
BE THE PRIMARY NETMINDER FOR A
JOSI , BLOCKED AWAY DOORSTEP.
THE REBOUND BY MEIER.   FIND TH
PUCK IN MID AIR AND GET A STICK
ON IT TO PUT IT TIMO MEIER.
A REBOUND
PREDATORS. RYAN JOHANSEN
>> Cassie: THIS IS WIDE OPEN
FOR SAN JOSE. BY REIMER.
JAMES RIDER IS  TO THIS OPPORTU